[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi
21 septembre tout de suite les titres de
cette édition c'est la journée mondiale
alzheimer en france près d'un million de
personnes sont touchées par la maladie
une entreprise élan courtoise blue line
ea vient de lancer une solution
d'accompagnement
on en parle avec laurent levasseur
président du directoire de giuly nea
il débarque dans les yvelines les yogis
du coeur c'est au programme dimanche à
l'orangerie du château de versailles
principe faire du yoga pour la bonne
cause sauvé quatre enfants malades
cardiaques que nous recevons sur ce
plateau ariane orange de mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque
organisateur de l'événement et puis
c'est jusqu'à dimanche l'open de tennis
de plaisir troisième plus grand rendez
vous de la discipline en ile de france
laissant la part belle aux espoirs
tricolores enjoy avant de développer ces
titres ce chiffre 200 mille euros
montant de l'aide d'urgence octroyés par
l île de france aux victimes de
l'ouragan rma les élus ont voté cette
enveloppe ce matin en séance du conseil
régional cela va servir à la
reconstruction des îles saint-martin et
saint-barthélémy dévasté par irna
et dans l'actualité du jour également
versailles reçoit le trophée d'honneur
une école un jardin prix décerné par le
fonds sylvain roger pour récompenser
l'engagement écocitoyen de la ville et
encourager le travail des écoles en
faveur de l'éducation à l'environnement
depuis plusieurs années 28 potager sont
installés et 36 établissements
versaillais trois éco jardinier sont
d'ailleurs missionnée par la ville
cérémonie en début d'après midi à la
mairie
propos recueillis par camille lambert
n'a vraiment une très grande vigilance à
cette question
d'abord parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
nature encore en ville et pour moi c'est
essentiel compris dans nos quartiers
sont sonnés fait très attention fait
notamment des gens d'un family qui
permettent de continuer à cultiver la
terre le fond si le verger pour la
sauvegarde des paysages et l'éducation à
l'environnement a pour vocation de
soutenir d'encourager et de doter toutes
les initiatives qui ont trait à
l'éducation à l'environnement la
biodiversité et ce trophée qui vient
aujourd'hui distinguer versaillais le
trophée d'honneur puisque c'est le la
ville qui a le plus de jardins potagers
dans ces écoles on vous en parlait dans
le 7-8 journal c'est la semaine
européenne de la mobilité
et dans ce cadre la verrière accueillait
aujourd'hui une étape du tour de vélo de
l'énergie citoyenne en ile de france
initiative portée par le collectif
alternatiba pour promouvoir ce type de
déplacement au profit de la voiture
retour sur cette journée avec hasna
allouache il a parcouru plus de 26
kilomètres pour sensibiliser le grand
public aux questions de l'environnement
cet ancien ingénieur consacre
aujourd'hui son temps au vélo le message
qu au passé c'est que ce changement
climatique est une vraie une vraie
catastrophe pour l'humanité c'est aussi
une formidable opportunité pour changer
la société pour passer à un autre
changer de paradigme effet une société
qui soit plus partageuse plus
bienveillante et finalement beaucoup
plus agréable à vivre
un engagement initié par sylvain ster
organisateurs de l'événement qui a prévu
ce tour à vélo mais aussi des
projections débats une démarche de
sensibilisation auprès du grand public
demandé par l'antenne nationale du
mouvement
il y avait cette volonté
du mouvement al rastan nationale faire
interdire de france découvrez-les
d'alternatives locales est proposée en
avait hier on avait un endroit avec
plein de l'inde au petit vélo trial cool
qui fonctionne donc c'était ça
l'objectif de cette journée c'était que
les cyclistes dû trouver des
alternatives à habas découvre les toutes
les belles choses qui se passent à la
dernière le tour à vélo de l'énergie
citoyenne continue toute la semaine
prochaine étape le 22 septembre à
versailles je vous le disais dans les
titres c'est la journée mondiale
alzheimer objectif informer et
sensibiliser le grand public sur cette
pathologie qui touche pas loin d'un
million de personnes en france c'est la
quatrième cause de mortalité dans
l'hexagone et pour aider les malades
entreprises associations s'organisent
nous recevons laurent levasseur bonsoir
bonsoir d'être le président du
directoire de blue line et à un mot
peut-être pour commencer sur cette
entreprise elle propose des services
d'accompagnement aux personnes souffrant
de troubles cognitifs
oui tout à fait on réfléchit chez nous
pourquoi il ya des personnes qui
vieillissent mieux que d'autres et on
travaille sur un aspect de la vie assez
simple réussir à prolonger l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé
on sait tous qu'on va vieillir très très
vieux mais tout de suite nous vient à
l'esprit mais dans quel état
et bien nos équipes travaillent sur dans
quel état et ça soit plutôt mieux que
moi bien un attachement c'est vieillir
aussi tout en conservant cette autonomie
c'est aussi l'un des lunes des priorités
pour pour blue line est assez de
développer des solutions qui rendent à
la personne âgée aussi autonome 90% des
personnes âgées souhaitent vieillir chez
elles le plus longtemps possible donc on
s'est intéressé à des solutions de
seniors connecter des détecteurs de chu
des boutons d'appel h 24 ce petit
bracelet pour personnes âgées meurent
dans paravan en parler leur en parler
et puis on s'est intéressés aussi à
l'habitat l'habitat connectés comment
développer des solutions pour que la
domotique la maison puisse être plus ou
moins agréables et pour conclure on est
aussi présent dans des maisons de
retraite donc on fait des ehpad
connectés et puis nous avons lancé un
concept d pad à domicile les premiers
lits d'ehpad à domicile avec la croix
rouge ouvre dans quelques semaines et je
rappelle que vous êtes basé à elancourt
à saint quentin en yvelines
vous avez lancé vous en avez parlé cette
semaine une nouvelle offre dédiée
spécifiquement aux malades d'alzheimer
elle blue garde de et c'est un bracelet
d'autonomie qui équipé d'un gps
voilà alors l'idée quand on a une
personne alzheimer dans sa famille c'est
d'éviter
de l'enfermer chez elle cette personne
n'est pas c'est pas parce qu'elle
alzheimer qui doit être contraintes à
rester chez elle enfermée
je dirais même que ça va pas l'aider et
ça va surtout pas aidé le conjoint
donc quand on met en place ce type de
bracelet enfin quand on va à la fois
protéger la personne
en gros plan alzheimer et on va aussi
apporter du répit à son conjoint on va
permettre à sa famille à son mari de se
réapproprier son quotidien
généralement cette personne va pouvoir
sortir de chez elle on va créer ce qu'on
appelle un espace de vie élargi c'est à
dire qu'on va tout simplement permettre
à cette personne se déplacer dans les
500 m 1 km et internet rhin voilà
comment on appelle une zone d'avis je
crois que vous avez un devis élargi
voilà et ça permet comme ça cette
personne de se promener
neuf fois sur dix c'est rentrer chez
elle et puis quand elles rentrent pas
chez elles ou quand tu avais un peu trop
loin
eh bien on va pouvoir guider son
entourage ses voisins sa famille où les
secours pour indiquer où est cette
personne et pouvoir la ramener la
raccompagner chez elle parce que
alzheimer la maladie d'alzheimer a
induit des pertes spatio-temporelle
c'est aussi important j'imagine
grâce à ce bracelet pouvoir intervenir
très rapidement quand cette personne
fort de cette veine de vie élargi oui
alors cette personne va à la fois sortir
de cette vie de sa zone de vie à va être
désorienté elle fut pas l air et en même
temps
devient pas file c'est à dire qu'il va
pas jeter sous les routes d'où les roues
d'une voiture va pas à se mettre à
chercher n'importe comment
c'est juste qu'elle ne sait plus où elle
va ou alors dans l'est dans les errances
les plus fortes les seuils de revenir là
où elle a grandi voilà tout simplement
et et quel rayon le périmètre où et
autour du domicile ça peut être aussi de
l'est pas de quelle date quel va être le
périmètre établi
c'est ça ça dépend aussi peut-être du
profil de la personne
vous mettez un accent important en fin
de contrat début on croyait qu'on allait
installer ses bracelets à des personnes
qui étaient plutôt chez elle en fin de
compte dans deux tiers des cas c'est
plutôt à des personnes qui souffrent de
maladies neurodégénératives en ehpad
d'accord ou alors dans les premiers
jours et on va pouvoir si jamais il y
avait un souci on peut suivre sept
personnes dans toute la france
on peut la retrouver il n'est pas rare
de voir des personnes prendre le train
et on les accompagnons les suivis à
distance
et puis bien sûr on peut aller jusqu'à
une centaine de mètres c'est à dire dès
lors qu'ils iraient au delà d'un parc
d'un jardin est bien de pouvoir
déclencher d'alerté et concrètement et
techniquement comment au détecte où se
trouve la personne si elle franchit
effectivement cette zone de vie comment
commencer détecter tout ça alors pour
cette personne il s'agit d'une montre
pour cette personne il s'agit de monde
parce qu'il faut qu'elle puisse vivre
avec ce dispositif
il est étanche et une forte autonomie
savoir c'est à dire là dessus maintenant
nous on va être informés quand cette
personne est sortie de sa zone énergie
et on va avoir des points gps toutes les
minutes
mais c'est pas la famille qui reçoit sa
c30 téléphone oui on a une plateforme h
24 7 jours sur 7 jours sur 7 h 24 accord
et nous appelons à ce moment là des
personnes qui sont déjà pré identifiés
pour leur dire on vient d'avoir une
alerte la personne est en train de
sortir elle en train de se promener à
tel endroit on la voit en train de
revenir ou pas quand il ya une alerte il
est urgent de ne pas se précipiter
ce que peut-être que la personne j'ai
juste un petit demi tour oui tout à fait
il faut pas créer non plus d'anxiété
trop forte et le timing l'intervention
vous êtes allé averti en temps et en
heure dans la minute d'accord dans la
minute on va savoir cette personne a
franchi cette zone et après on peut la
suivre pendant plusieurs heures
tout simplement donc vous en parliez à
la base c'était c'est l'idée de ce
projet c'était pour les personnes vivant
à domicile là c'est donc nous bien
concrètement combien de maisons de
retraite actuellement combien d pad a
aujourd'hui on a plus de 200 maisons de
retraite qui sont équipées de ce
dispositif dans chacune de ces maisons
de retraite on va avoir entre entre une
5 10 personnes qui sont équipés et puis
on a à peu près un millier de personnes
à domicile qui sont équipés aussi de
cette solution et c'est un bracelet
aussi qu'à développer avec une start up
belge ainsi dit pas de bêtise
alors qui est devenu industriel au
départ ils choisissaient j'ai cherché à
faire un bracelet bras et d'autres
usages et nous on a détourné cet usage
et on a même ajouté un petit dispositif
qui évite que cette personne puisse
sortir et elle même comme ça on peut
suivre cette personne plus longtemps et
on a pu faire grandir cette société en
les choisissant les familles peuvent
s'équiper pour une somme un abonnement
ils ne sont pas propriétaires dispositif
est dans cet abonnement il ya l'objet il
y à l'accès à la plateforme h 24 et puis
on met en place un petit un petit
solidarité avec les voisins avec la
famille tout ça pour 69 euros par mois
deux mois très rapidement pour terminer
le brass a été lancé cette semaine 4
qu'attendez-vous finalement de ce
lancement
alors le lancement de cette semaine
c'est la version 2 auparavant elle avait
un bras c'est un peu plus gros qui était
peut-être un peu trop présent désormais
on a un bracelet qui est assez actuelle
on a l'impression que c'est un bracelet
que n'importe qui pourrait avoir dans le
cadre d' objets connectés et on voit les
anciens bracelet le voilà qui est fait
et là on a maintenant un bracelet
plus actuels dans son design l'autonomie
est beaucoup plus renforcée il est
étanche des personnes prendre leur
douche avec leur bain avec est d'ores et
déjà on en a diffusé plusieurs centaines
en quelques jours merci à laurent
levasseur d'avoir été avec nous je le
rappelle président du directoire de blue
line et à l'entreprise propose des
solutions d'accompagnement pour les
personnes atteintes d'alzheimer et de
troubles cognitifs plus d'informations
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
autre engagement contre la maladie
d'alzheimer la fondation ups qu
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines le professeur joël ankri
directeur de l'unité de recherche
vieillissement et maladies chroniques
oeuvre dans l'espoir de trouver un
traitement à la pathologie
pour ce faire l'équipe du professeur en
cris a besoin de votre soutien vous
pouvez faire un don via le site internet
de la fondation
il aura pour but de faire progresser la
recherche et d'améliorer
l'accompagnement des patients et aidant
on reparle de santé dans un instant mais
d'abord trouver le parfait baby sitter
pour son enfant un moment pas toujours
facile pour les familles qui ne savent
pas forcément où chercher à montigny le
bretonneux le pôle jeunesse organise des
babys site dating rencontres entre
jeunes étudiants et parents sur le pré
le principe du job dating focus de
camille lambert
ils sont lycéens ou étudiants
et ce soir ils trouveront peut-être leur
famille pour du baby sitting
clémence est étudiante à l'université de
versailles saint quentin et ce mode de
rencontre
tim job dating lui plaît beaucoup j'ai
déjà fait quelques années et ça avait
bien marché
et parce que j'ai eu comme beaucoup
d'étudiants on n'est jamais contre avoir
un petit job on peut faire aussi via des
agences mais si c'est plus compliqué je
trouve c'est moins direct là c'est plus
vivant rencontre des gens directement
voilà ils peuvent a ressenti sur le coup
on donne notre cv donc c'est un peu
quand même sérieux il voit un peu près
qui on est déjà dès les cinq premières
minutes après plusieurs entretiens pour
échanger sur son parcours et ses
disponibilités
clémence ressort plutôt confiante
footeux des retours positifs
il ya pas mal de familles qui sont
intéressés par mon profil impression on
verra bien mais organisé par le pôle
jeunesse de montigny le bretonneux cette
septième édition a attiré une
soixantaine de familles ça fonctionne
bien depuis la première année parce
qu'en fait ça répond à un besoin des
familles qui recherchent à la rentrée
des solutions de garde soient ponctuels
soit régulière et ne savent pas trop où
trouver des jeunes
ça donne la possibilité de rencontrer
des jeunes qui sont dans la même commune
donc ça c'est un point positif c'est
vrai que je privilégiais le feeling
physique plutôt que des petites annonces
à qu'il faut éplucher et qui finalement
disent pas grand chose une nouvelle
session de baby seal dating est
programmée samedi 23 septembre pour y
participer les inscriptions se font
auprès du pôle jeunesse du yoga pour la
bonne cause après paris et le grand
palais l'an passé les yogis du coeur se
déroule dimanche dans les yvelines
ça se passe à l'orangerie du château de
versailles 800 personnes attendues avec
un seul objectif récolter des fonds pour
opérer quatre enfants atteints de
malformations cardiaques avec nous sur
ce plateau ariane orange bonsoir ça vous
êtes chef de projet à mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque qui organise ces yogi du coeur
alors malheureusement l'événement est
déjà complet mais il était normal de le
mettre en lumière pourquoi le thème du
yoga pour rassembler autour de cette
cause voilà sauver ses enfants malades
du coeur bat c'est un bel événement
solidaire un grand événement peut faire
ce qu'on peut toucher plein plein de
gens différents à versailles et le voilà
toute cette communauté et tous qui
s'engage auprès de nous
ça fait quatre ans qu'on organise ce
rassemblement ça a beaucoup beaucoup de
succès on a réussi à sauver plus de dix
enfants donc c'est magnifique pour
sauver un enfant il nous faut douze
mille euros donc à chaque fois qu on en
sauve un c'est une vraie fête est là
tous et yogi qui se mettent ensemble et
se mobilisent pendant un grand moment
c'est beau c'est à l'orangerie du
château de versailles
ces prestigieuses voilà et c'est un
grand moment voilà alors vous l'avez dit
quatrième année consécutive que sont
organisés c'est jodie du coeur est
d'ailleurs un clin d'oeil cette année
ils reviennent au à l'orangerie du
château de versailles qui était le lieu
d'où tout est parti
exactement c'est issu de professeur de
yoga qui s'appelle anne loca qui aime
beaucoup l'association et ben voilà qui
a voulu mobiliser ses yogi et puis se
trouve que une de ses élèves qui étaient
yogi travailler au château de versailles
voilà comment ça a commencé à 10h
peut-être pouvoir demander tout le monde
peut-être avoir une opportunité
ils m'ont prêté une fois deux fois on
avait fait une petite une petite ans
partait l'année dernière on a réussi à
avoir le grand palais donc là on était
plus de 2000 et on est revenue ils nous
ont accepté gentiment voilà on de la
dernière à l'est très impressionnant 6 2
milieux guy et cette année on retourne
avec grand grand plaisir à l'orangerie
du château de versailles qui est un lieu
magique majestueux voile avec cette
grande verrière c'est superbe
on rappelle événements ont
malheureusement déjà complet le tarif
d'entrée est à 25 euros pour les adultes
15 euros pour les enfants
donc ces fonds-là dit on servira à
opérer ses quatre enfants malades du
coeur une opération qui coûte douze
mille euros exactement voilà ça fait 20
ans que l'association existe en vingt
ans on va avoir opéré trois mille
enfants
c'est un combat perpétuel on opère deux
cents enfants par an il faut savoir
qu'on soit 150 demandes par mois donc
donc voilà on essaye de sauver le plus
possible et c'est grâce à des événements
comme ça où on peut sauver un deux trois
quatre enfants qu'on arrive à lever des
fonds et qu'on arrive à les opérer et
petit à petit ses enfants une viennent
de pays défavorisés s'adresse à des
enfants qui souffre de grave grave
malformation cardiaque y viennent de 80
pays dans le monde
on peut pas les opérés dans ces pays là
ils sont condamnés ils faut qu'ils
viennent en france et leurs moyens de
venir c'est grâce à l'association
donc ils vont venir pendant deux mois
ils seront accueillis par des familles
d'accueil qui vont s'occuper de ses
enfants comme si c'était leur propre
enfant ils vont avoir cette opération
qui est une opération très lourde à
coeur ouvert très compliqué c'est pour
ça qu'on veut pas le faire dans ces
pays-là et repartiront deux mois plus
tard avec un coeur tout neuf dans leur
famille les parents voilà vous imaginez
la joie c'est une renaissance
ils s'étaient des enfants qui étaient
condamnés et qu'ils vont pouvoir revivre
comme d'autres enfants et vont pouvoir
courir ils vont pouvoir mener à bien
leur scolarité
et voilà c'est un vrai bonheur de mots
peut-être encore sur les yogis du coeur
le programme de la matinée y aura
différents professeurs qui seront
présents aussi pour cet événement mais
ils sont trois professeurs là ça se
déroule en trois temps
il ya de la méditation enfin bon c'est
il ya plein de choses et puis il ya
aussi des mini yogi pour les enfants qui
sont dans une salle à côté et voilà
j'espère que ceux qui peuvent pas venir
cette année pourront venir l'année
prochaine qui se voilent à savoir que
les places sont chères ils sont durs on
est juste 800 et c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup de demandes parce que c'est
c'est un événement qui est vraiment
incroyable
alors vous en parler de ces familles
d'accueil aussi qui sont primordiales
pour accueillir ces enfants mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque qui est en recherche
perpétuelle ou et de familles d'accueil
exact notamment dans les yvelines
on a beaucoup de familles d'accueil dans
les yvelines parce que les enfants se
font opérer à paris et aussi en eau
perdante au fil en france mais à paris
notamment et après ils vont en centre de
convalescence au château des côtes à aux
loges en josas donc voila tout à côté de
versailles donc c'est vrai qu'on a une
grande communauté de familles d'accueil
qui sont les yvelines si ça vous
intéresse c'est une histoire incroyable
dont internet
jean alesi renseignez vous on vous
donnera tous les renseignements
possibles mais c'est une histoire
magique que je vois là je peux que vous
l'a conseillé de faire moi même famille
d'accueil et qu'elles vont être là cette
année les autres actions dans le
département des yvelines
à l'intérieur de ces drames en début de
l'année prochaine on va avoir un grand
rassemblement comme chaque année de golf
à au golf de saint nom la bretèche
voilà un trophée de golf qui aura lieu
au printemps est là à paris on va avoir
un on va avoir une grande fête on va
opérer notre 3000e enfants le cirque
gruss nous offre une représentation donc
on attend trois mille personnes si vous
voulez venir voilà passer un bon moment
avec nous c'est le 17 octobre vous
pouvez pareil trouver vos billets sur le
site internet
et puis on a aussi un beau rassemblement
c'est un marché de noël au palais des
congrès qui aura lieu lui le 17 décembre
et un grand rassemblement solidaire
pareil au profit de mécénat et là on
arrive aussi pareil à sauver dix enfants
grâce à des courses solidaire vraiment
très rapide qu'on a déjà terminé cet
entretien l'association s'associe aussi
à tanguy de lamotte le skipper
versaillais et qui peut grâce à aux
courses le vendée globe était le dernier
en date je crois sauver des enfants il
ya une campagne de dons qui est
organisée cliquer sur sur le site
facebook sur la page facebook et un euro
est reversé à chaque fois
automatiquement par ses sponsors et
mécènes qui nous reverse un euro donc y
est on arrive à sauver 20 enfants voilà
et là ça va être la transat jacques
vabre début novembre sportif
merci ariane orange avoir été avec nous
je rappelle chef de projet à mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque et au delà des yogis
du coeur ce dimanche à versailles vous
pouvez bien sûr faire un don à
l'association à n'importe quel moment
rendez vous sur le site internet qui
s'affiche pour nos téléspectateurs
c'est un classique à rambouillet le
cinquième festif auto se tient samedi et
dimanche à la bergerie nationale et des
photographes animaliers y exposent leurs
oeuvres
animations ateliers mais aussi
conférences sont également au menu du
week end à les détails avec mathilde
demi
faune et flore sont dans l'objectif
cette année à rambouillet pour le
festival ouvert à tous festi photo
renard chouette ou encore sert prennent
la pose pour l'édition 2017
on va retrouver des animaux qui se
trouvent sur des îles subantarctiques
comme des animaux qui sont dans la taïga
des ours des ours polaires mais à la
fois des ours bruns et à la fois de la
faune extrêmement locale c'est à dire ce
qu'on trouve dans la forêt de
rambouillet ou dans la beauce un
festival qui permet de mettre en avant
une faune et une flore locale ainsi que
de faire voyager le public à travers le
monde par la photo un festival de ce
type là à plusieurs but d'initier les le
grand public on va dire aux choses de la
nature et à la fois c'est de faire venir
du monde en local donc des festivals de
certaine importance peuvent rassembler
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes et on essaie de présenter le
maximum de choses intéressantes qui se
passe aussi bien sur le plan local que
sur le plan je dirais tous les
continents
c'est vraiment une ouverture sur le
monde
des expositions des rencontres avec les
photographes des ateliers et sorties
nature seront proposées durant tout le
festival a retrouvé le 22 23 et dans le
cas de septembre ces petites briques ont
sûrement marqué à votre enfance et
continue de faire des adeptes
les lego sortie en 1932 il semble
indémodable opéré en yvelines des
collectionneurs organise une exposition
ce week-end une trentaine de passionnés
feront découvrir leurs créations
le président de l'association breezy qui
organise l'événement également aux
préparé quelques animations
présentations au micro de camille
lambert
on a 35 exposants qui vont venir en tout
donc ça va être assez varié ça valait le
lego technic
minecraft on va voir du coup city des
bateaux vraiment une étendue assez varié
de ce qui existe dans les eaux et pour
la partie animation on va avoir une
mosaïque on va avoir des briques en
accès libre pour pouvoir jouer d'une
piscine de duplo une piscine également
pour pouvoir guider des bateaux du sport
à présent jusqu'à dimanche le
tennis-club de plaisir organise un
tournoi futures plus de 600 joueurs
présents chaque année pour cet événement
parmi eux les futures pépites sa du
tennis français reportage de nickel et
demi d'euros c'est le troisième plus
gros tournoi de tennis en ile-de-france
la 27ème édition de l'open de plaisir se
déroule jusqu'au 24 septembre au tennis
club de la commune cette année plus de
600 joueurs venus de toute l'europe
s'affrontent sur l'école les matches
sont très disputées les joueurs ça vont
gagner quelques points atp qui vont leur
permettre de défaire des trois
challengers demain et peut être demain
des grands chelems donc tout ça c'est
une évidence et c'est pour cette raison
que ce tournoi me plaît bien
c'est le sport de haut niveau qui a son
visage naturel si je puis dire
avec sa dotation à 25000 dollars le
rendez-vous est intégré au futur la 6è
catégorie des tournois de tennis
déjà on a des arbitres à la déchetterie
après c'est un futur en avait des
changements de balle on a des serviettes
on a des bouteilles d'eau ça a fait on
est un peu comme un sur un mini mini
rolland ou universitaire s manche a pas
et on est considérés comme des très bons
joueurs donc ça fait toujours plaisir
sur le plan sportif le tournoi est
réputé pour faire éclore des talents
l'événement a révélé de nombreux
professionnels tricolore c'est quoi ces
les futurs champions de demain
lee chong aller mahut et cetera les
lieux de drague compagnies sont passés
par là donc nous avons les futurs
champions de demain
la future pépite du tennis français se
trouve peut-être sur les courts cette
année si vous voulez les voir à l'oeuvre
et finales sont programmées ce dimanche
24 septembre à partir de 13h30 sur les
courts plaisir au petit retour en
arrière avant de refermer ce journal
montigny le bretonneux rouler aux
couleurs italiennes le week-end dernier
plein phare sur l'auto c'était le rendez
vous des passionnés de voitures de
collection une trentaine de
collectionneurs ont défilé dans les rues
de la commune nicolas landry et mélanie
poker se sont glissés parmi les amateurs
c'est une vieille dame de 60 ans
l'italienne fiat 500 l'une des stars de
cette troisième édition de pleins phares
sur l'auto
nous fêtons les 10 ans de jumelage avec
marostica donc c'était
ensuite le but de cet événement est de
mettre en valeur les vieilles voitures
non vieilles voitures des vieilles
voitures de la france et du monde en
l'occurrence cette année l'italie et de
le faire venir les amateurs de vieilles
voitures qui rêve toujours autour d'elle
maserati ferrari lamborghini
des noms qui font rêver les passionnés
24 voitures anciennes comme récente une
exception cette année elle attend donc
la vitesse foudroyante de 120 km bref
quelle vitesse enfin c'est pas une vraie
4 c'est une scion multiplier une
troisième une surmultipliée quoi alors
non ça c'est une voiture dont j'ai
hérité il ya dix ans mon cas de
l'effectif que j'ai connus minots et
voilà donc très attachante
c'est une petite série parce que limité
il y en a pas beaucoup en fait de ce
type là il ya beaucoup et de gran
turismo s c'est un véhicule qui est
assez récent et dans les finitions sont
quasi complète je veux dire il ya
beaucoup d'options
après un détour par le passé retour au
présent plaisir des yeux et des oreilles
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
retrouvez nous également sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
60,18 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]